Troy Duffy is on the line with us to
talk about Boondock Saints 1 & 2 what
he's up to and the world according to
Troy Troy Duffy is the writer director
of The Boondock Saints and the boondock
saints All Saints Day on March 11th
which is in four days there is a
nationwide special one night release of
the original Boondock Saints to
celebrate the film's 10-year anniversary
Troy and members of The Boondock Saints
family are currently touring the country
on the boondock saints tour bus
celebrating this 10-year anniversary
it's stopping at colleges and venues
holding parties for fans and you know
giving thank you for their support so
let us welcome to film courage mr. Troy
Duffy hello Troy welcome hey gar yeah
we're doing great excellent you know
thank thank you for joining us today joy
for those of you listening live if you
have questions for Troy you know our
Twitter has already been blowing up our
our Gmail has already been blowing up
but you can send them through twitter at
film courage any inquiries you have off
the air you can send through Twitter or
or three male film crews at gmail.com
okay so before we get to your background
Troy's since you are on tour where are
you right now and how many days does
this tour continue she's not a couple of
weeks we're going through southern named
Ontario Canada right now crossing back
of eating last week in Toronto last
night where we actually shot both films
boondock wanted to in Toronto we're kind
of thinking for Kostas to commander
there the tax rebates and the American
dollar the strength of the American
dollar both times it's kind of a little
independent film trick when you think
about it save yourself some money
stretch a dollar up here in Canada we
came back to see these fans and a bunch
of the actors that had pulled out of the
Toronto talent pool a great time last
night and now we're going to join New
York on teams day I believe you know and
about your tour tour we have this
two-part question already from from a
fan from Austria award any chance that
you will make it to San Francisco and
secondly who would I need to beg yeah
san Francisco's probably not
and because we're you know we're on the
opposite end of the country right now so
look for we've got kind of a lot a bunch
of dates concentrated in a Ohio
Pennsylvania New York Boston sort of
area and then we're cruising back to LA
but we would probably probably going to
have something in California maybe Long
Beach or something like that okay there
you go after yep you have to make it
down to Long Beach so stay tuned for
that now Troy I read that you're from
Hartford Connecticut houses David is
that right yeah I was born there but
it's not weird to say you're from there
I don't remember we all announced or the
New England seacoast when I was a kid so
I'm from many different places in in in
Connecticut Massachusetts in New
Hampshire
okay and when did you decide you were
going to move to LA and what led you to
that decision I was dropped on a school
after about a year and a half and I want
to be a musician so I just packed up you
know my dreams in my van and moved out
to Los Angeles and the you know the
scriptwriting thing happens years later
no I mean how did your creative passion
developed or like when did you realize
you know what I want to do something
creative with my life I don't want to
work a 9 to 5 job I guess I always kind
of knew that in the back of my head I
always doing something creatives you
know even down kind of different copies
that are creating my hands working
always been a guitar player you know I
read all the time my father make all of
his children read a novel a month
extra-curricular Lee in our childhood we
give it all book report to the whole
family if you had the beach months no
matter no matter what you know you know
you're not yelling you want to be out
there playing ball but my father was
showing us what good writing was and how
about how that was different from bad
writing or chameleon writing and you
know made me a bit of a novel a holic so
I'm an avid reader
and lighting was just came kind of kind
of natural I don't regard sort of book
writing the same as script writing
scripts aren't really you know they're
not for reading so much being made into
something else being made into a film so
that seems like an easier thing for me
you know when I decided to sit down and
write one you know them actually about a
book which you know at that point you're
standing on the shoulders a giant so
that was a little scary for me I admire
the belief and confidence you have in
yourself where does that come from you
have no idea I guess the Duffy's have
always been kind of a tough little plan
you know yeah
we're just you know brought up to be a
little bit more self-reliant than most
there's plenty to because when I was you
know going through high school in
college you start realizing that some
kids got you know parents that do
everything buy him a car and kid comes
home he's got you know milk and cookies
waiting for him in there that never
really happened in my family and that I
actually think that it does them a
disservice growing up if they're coddled
too much you know yeah I agree
can you share the inspiration you know
what pulled you away from music to write
the script I mean in those books that
you read every month
were there any on-screen writing no no I
never read any books on screenwriting or
anything like that but uh I suppose I
was just motivated I was in Los Angeles
you know my brother and I and the
friends of ours one band together and I
kind of had to get this off my chest you
know it was just something I had always
been thinking about little stories and
little bits of dialogues pop in my hand
every now and then so I just thought to
myself jeez we've got to be some reason
for it mostly I just put it in songs but
now I'm thinking all right why don't we
try writing a script and I'm in Los
Angeles everybody's been a goddamn
script anyway right so I had borrowed a
friend's like I had a buddy that worked
at a production company gave me a script
that was actually made into a movie so I
could watch the film and read the script
and see how it was done and I just said
to copied the format
and wrote Boondock Saints and my friend
Chris breaker happened to be an
assistant at New Line Cinema I guess it
was the right assistant and he asked if
you could handle it I said sure go ahead
not really expecting anything and next
thing you know it was like created quite
a buzz in Hollywood now Tori what was
the boondock saints script was that was
that the first script that you wrote
yeah so so you literally pass it off to
your friend and and I mean can you can
you give us a little bit more detail in
terms of what led talk to sort of this
this buying frenzy around the script
from this unknown unheralded writer yeah
you know it's funny because I had the
instant patron of every writer in town
when I saw my script because I was my
first good sign ever written you know
there's a lot of writers he's just
banging it out every day they've got 10
15 20 scripts sometimes another whole
career without cell Union so I was
immediately a sort of an outcast among
the Hollywood writer sect but it just
kind of happened strangely you know and
what my producers tell me and what my
agents at the time told me it was just
that kind of writing that just separated
itself from all the other stuff I mean
if you think about these guys in
Hollywood they read the same types of
scripts over and over and over again you
know so when something new hits their
desk they sort of you know stand up take
note that will they enjoy reading
something for a change when they when
they see something new on that page that
affects them differently and that's what
happened with the doctor and what was
the time frame I mean you know in terms
of when you handed it off to your friend
and all of a sudden it starts getting
filtered in through the system how much
times you know was transpiring but
before all of a sudden there was heavy
interest and you and you had people
fighting for fur to make this film I
think it happened within a couple of
months maybe two months maybe two and a
half months we got CP he was assistant
at New Line Cinema and he was sort of
obligated
enough is he obviously want to be a
producer he's worked himself up to the
ranch there and he was obligated to go
to new line first
but while the Prince contacts a new line
passed on Boondock Saints when they
first got it and then suddenly some of
it started getting a lot of heat after
that you know suddenly I'm being courted
by William Morris Agency CAA all these
large talent agents so now people are
starting to revisit the script that he
first came in to but not by now it's
kind of kind of expanded out everywhere
you know and Harvey Weinstein got a copy
of it and said he wanted to move on it
right away
by that time Michael ook over new I am
found out that it was a script that had
originated within his house and here's
Harvey Weinstein moving on it so he he
grabs the script reads it and he decides
he wants it so it becomes a bidding war
between the two which Miramax ultimately
won you know and that and that's where
you're speaking under that that's what
leads me here you know you this whole
legendary story where where Mary mock
Miramax bought your scripts with you
attached to direct that you know they
offered somewhere something like 300,000
for the script and an additional hundred
fifty thousand to direct an edit and and
you were gonna be given a fifteen
million dollar budget for the film your
band would do the soundtrack sauce on
track and they were even gonna throw in
co-ownership of Jace loans which is the
bar where you worked so you know long
with this story is a documentary done on
you that chronicles your struggle to
complete the original Boondock Saints
and it includes your eventual falling
out with Miramax this isn't something we
want to harp on here on the show but I
bring it up because the film is
one-sided you know it's a hatchet job
and and you know this is our first time
speaking with you but we know a lot of
people that know you and speak very
highly of you for those of you for those
listening who only know you by the
documentary you know I would love for
you to just squash it right here right
now yeah I mean it's something that yeah
it's really strange because most
reporters and critics
seem to really want to believe that
story they want to believe that that's
true and that's exactly the way it
happened and I am this huge
they never and it's funny too because he
is supposed to be the objective people
they never taken a second go wait a
minute
what was their real agreement here
what's the story I mean it's pretty easy
to make somebody look like an
and you don't give the who what why
where when what the audience make their
own decision what you saw was a gender
driven piece by two opportunistic
who decided to screw over
everybody that ever helped them what
happened was these guys been planning on
bootstrapping their documentary to boom
box ain't so it didn't get a theatrical
release because of the Columbine
incident they thought that that was it
done all this work for nothing so their
answer to that was to disappear to the
hills with their footage and a year
later we see this thing they went
sensationalistic on it is an untruthful
piece and I suppose you know it helps me
kind of weed out the weak ones from the
herd if anybody totally buys into that I
mean because I'm nobody would invest six
dollars in that guy never mind six
million it took to make that film you
know my ultimate answer I guess to it is
every piece of cast including Rome the
phone came back and did a sequel for me
what are these people masochists they
signed up for another you know three
months torture from Troy it just it
doesn't have it didn't happen that way
what you see is a kid fighting for his
film and fighting for the careers of his
bandmates and his friends and that can
be edited together to just give you a
sensationalistic aspects of the story
without giving you the background of
what happened I guarantee this every
young filmmaker that's out there that
saw that if they actually knew what I
was yelling about and who I was yelling
at and why and what the situation was
they would not absorbed it the way that
they did I in fact think most of them
would have been on my side
I've always been a fighter I will
continue to be a fighter you have to be
in my opinion in independent film that's
what I did for those three very
tumultuous years I just made the mistake
of letting two friends of mine follow me
around the video camera when I did it
let's also bring up Columbine because
didn't the film get released right
around that time and when you heard
about Columbine what was your what was
your thought yeah I knew it was gonna
affect us I mean frankly the the the
commonplace things to do for young
filmmakers is to get your film made
however possible some guys pick into
their pocket credit card have their moms
come in they got a financier some get
your movie made and then what they do is
they have screenings at the studio Lots
hoping that you know a Sony or a
Paramount or whatever will buy their
film and get behind it and put it out in
theaters and that's what we were trying
to do too and our screenings were
extremely well attended and the audience
reactions off the charts and yet it
wasn't getting bought and we all kind of
knew it because it was about two weeks
after Columbine I mean the day we had
our first screening Bill Clinton landed
in Los Angeles threatening the former
Judiciary Committee to censor violent
felon video games and the industry's
reaction to that was to bend right over
and grab their nickels as usual so
nobody was going to touch Boondock
Saints just and there was actually even
an acquisitions guy from from a was
actually an acquisitions guy from the
studio who actually came up and said you
know you've been blacklisted from
computer screens in the US no I want to
take this moment I want to I want to
come back because we have a question
coming in from filmmaker Thomas Corcoran
he says after seeing the documentary
overnight I found your personal and
creative journey during the during the
years that surrounded Boondock Saints
compelling to say the least my question
to you is why haven't you directed any
smaller scale films that while possibly
not having the commercial scope of
Boondock Saints would have been stepping
stones to get you back to where you
deserve to be you are a not you are
natural at filmmaking
how would you respond to that story well
I am I have the the slight station of
being a writer director and I can't
imagine doing it any other way so I need
you know I'm more comfortable directing
and making films on my own stuff that's
not always possible and some of it is
smaller films than boondock just like he
suggested i've got about I think five
scripts that I've written over the last
bunch of years while we were struggling
to get boondock to mate and I'm going to
try to knock them down one by one but
it's not so much you know the the size
of the material in terms of small
independents our larger budget films
it's just what the right material is at
the time when you make a cult film like
boondock one and you've got an audience
of millions of people crying out for a
sequel that's the next movie you do when
you're lucky enough to know what the
audience wants you do it a hundred
percent of the time or you're making a
huge mistake kids and this is this this
audience of people for boondock did not
want to see you know my version of
precious or frozen river come on to see
boondock too and I fought until I was
able to give it to him so that's why I
didn't do anything in-between
although I was made a couple of offers
from from places to you know do two
films they just didn't happen to be the
right ones didn't like the writing and
you know also knew personally that I had
a very large fan base out there that
only wanted one thing can you talk about
the inner resolve that you had to see
this film through I don't know that I
did have an inner result I mean in terms
of seeing the film through making it and
stuff like that that's where your inner
resolve comes in in terms of its success
that's when you got a hand the ball off
to the audience the audience will film's
going to be in that
that I did everything I could and I
crawled across the finish line you know
bloody and beaten but I learned
something extremely but it's valuable to
me if you build it they will come you
make a good movie no matter if it's
theatrical II released or not the kids
are gonna find it and make it a success
on their own so I wouldn't say that I
gave up I'd say that I me and all these
actors and producers struggled like hell
to get this thing across the finish line
and get it made and then when Columbine
happened we were denying a theatrical
release that we so richly deserved that
was a that was a very depressing moment
and there's nothing you can do at that
point your movies gone straight to video
and that's that it was at that point
when we could do no more that the
audience came in and found it and did
what and did the rest of it for us
when kids found this on those
blockbuster shelves it instantly created
a forest fire in public that spread and
spread and spread
that's what more like ah you know yeah
you can all you have to do is make a
good film and the kids will find it and
make it successful on their own and
boondock saints has become a financial
juggernauts been selling in record
levels for the last ten years when the
exploitation of most films is three to
six months tops and then it's over
boondock has been constantly selling in
audience it's been constantly growing
and that's what I that's what I'm most
proud of we we we broke our asses but it
was the it was the fans who actually
made it happen at the end of the day so
Satori was that the lowest moment and
the whole point was when you didn't get
that the astral deal and if there wasn't
the lowest point what was the lowest
point for you I'd have to say that was
the lowest point man I mean imagine that
I look at that timing here I'll come out
with a film it's even got some some
crazy parallels to you know I got the
trench coat mafia stuff that was power
Atacama I got two characters where
trench coats the whole movie the
violence was committed by two young guys
in Columbine I got two young guys
committing violent you know depicting
violence
myself I mean it was like the worst
timing of all time in the theater
business and the fact that it suddenly
was reflecting directly on film and
video games right when we were trying to
get our our thing off the ground I mean
it seemed like you know the world had
conspired against us you know and and
they just learned budget nobody would
give us a shot so that was the blackest
point and then I guess the the the the
most bright point was when the audience
found it and it started boondock started
doing its thing man you know we did
everything we can and and frankly handed
the ball off to the kids you know they
dragged it across the finish line for us
and then how did that happen how did the
audience find the film you know I
obviously it went straight to the home
market but but what my how did how did
it reach people how did people discover
how do they find it well first it was
blockbuster blockbusters thought it was
pretty unfair what was happening to this
Columbine thing especially with AH
station so they released it in what's
called a blockbuster exclusive which
means they put about 60 to 120 copies
per store and released it as if it were
a bigger film and they also really loved
the movie and thought that it would be
you know thought that it would make
sense um it would do well financially
right so they stuck it in there and
immediately it became the
highest-grossing straight-to-video hit
you know and blockbusters calling us up
and going guys this is we can't keep
this thing on the shelves and also that
was the first indication we got from
that point forward I mean it's kids
finding it on their own I'm if a critic
comes up if a critic writes a review or
reviews a movie on TV poorly or good
I've never gone to see a movie or not
seeing movie based on what a critic said
but when my friend comes up to me and
says dude you have to check this you
know 100 percent of the time I do it so
you've got these fans that are spreading
the word on their own they want us to
see their faces their buddy's faces
change and laugh uncertain thing they
want to be the guy that brought boondock
into their world it becomes like a thing
where it's become very very personal and
let's not forget these kids were never
after
Tidus to drink you know television
commercials saying please come see
boondock saints they filed it on their
own so it became a much more personal
thing for them which is why this fan
base is completely rabid you know I run
into people all the time with the
tattoos related to the film all over
their bodies
you know these fans are ahold of read
the most movie fans
for all the filmmakers listening and for
those getting ready to sign away their
rights to their film what do they need
to know yeah that's it that's a that's a
that's a strange story was a boy wasn't
not only just not going to me but also
the actors who had back end in the film
the producers you know this was we made
the mistake of getting involved with a
completely unscrupulous company and one
of the reasons boondock 2 took 10 years
because we initiated a lawsuit again
financier distributors of boondock one
in which the sequel rights were tied so
that was a fight we just had to take on
because what they did was unconscionable
this was a movie that only costs six
million dollars its global growth is
this is just speculation but it's got to
be around the 200 million dollar mark at
this point from what we know and to
suggest that that film had not recouped
its original budget was ludicrous
especially since you know your actors
and stuff they're running into people
all the time oh my god blue and dark
saying and it's making top-ten lists all
over the place and we're not seeing a
diamond that luckily I had the
merchandising rights so I was able to
open up a website and stuff and so you
know boondock merchandise and keep my
head you know my personal head above
water but you know not a lot of the
money that was covered the millions and
millions and millions of dollars it was
coming in not a penny of it was going to
anybody that made the movie in here we
are waving around our contracts to kids
that believe you can't do a hundred
million dollar hit and not make it make
us and I'm living proof that that can
happen and what I learned I think is
that it matters the the company that you
make to deal with in the individuals
within that company or what matter
because it doesn't really matter what a
contract says I've learned that in
courts that it's completely arguable you
can though it seems like it's sitting
there in black and white
how can you misunderstand that you get
to the courts and all of a sudden it's a
different story our contract was pretty
much ironclad
they did this to us anyway just
expecting that we wouldn't sue them well
they thought wrong about that I think
the major thing I learned was though you
have to get an ironclad contract with a
scrupulous company you know working with
a studio on the second time around so
nice of a small indie house I mean look
at it this way
it can't be small indie houses you'll
make 10 films chances are only one of
them is going to make money and they're
in the hole on you know millions of
dollars of budgets for the other mind
they got one film that's bringing in
money you can bet your ass that they're
not going to turn around and give it to
the film makers as per the contract well
they got to keep their lights on and pay
down their own bills when I look around
the the independent film landscape Troy
I do not see many filmmakers who have
amassed that the rabid fan base that
this fan support that you have and and I
believe this is a key obviously to how
you have resurrected your career not not
all of us at this point can can take a
tour bus around the country and connect
with the fans the way you are right now
but can you share specifically the ways
you began to build your fan base and
what you have done to nurture this fan
base well I mean you know you get a
website and commune with them and you
listen to their opinions and stuff
but if the fan base you know amassed
itself and its continuing to grow every
day you know in terms of what I do and
you know like being able to jump on a
tour bus and say yeah sure maybe maybe a
lot of people aren't
unable to do that but you know we we
this is sort of tangibility to our crew
you know when a boondocks Anne comes up
here there's no there's no BS involved
you know that they're a fan they know
every line of this movie so communing
with these people with some of the
funnest things that you can ever do I
mean just last night we shot and norm
sat there signing autographs for a
couple of hours taking pictures it's
just fun stuff but in terms of sort of
activating that fan base you know and
and and grouping them together on
certain sites and stuff that we haven't
contacting them for the things that
we're doing
you know all the all the IT guys on the
crew are pretty good at that so whose
idea was it for you to speak directly to
the fans on your YouTube channel
yeah any young filmmaker to try to to
try to do that too I mean they were able
to keep their finger on the pulse of
production through making a film with
these little YouTube videos Seana more
messing around you know dancing camera
me you know I would answer fan questions
it keeps them excited about the movie
knowing and it also keeps them heartened
that it's actually being made and going
to come out after ten years of waiting
you know so that kind of stuff is
invaluable and what's been the best
thing that's happened so far on the
boondock saints tour oh god no if I
could pick one the other night is like a
couple seven items night this guy this
guy couldn't get in for some reason and
I'm out there having a cigarette and I'm
talking to me rich sawfish series death
to the brothers prayer taxis all the way
down its back and he's got Connor Murphy
and Billy Connolly tattooed across his
chest and I just grabbed him and took
him inside I was like don't worry we'll
we'll find a spot for you so that was
pretty cool but I mean on any given
evening ten things like that happen and
you know fans it's funny too one of the
really funny things is they genuinely
don't think they think that there's I
think they're so jaded by the sort of
wall between Hollywood and the fan base
but they don't actually think we're
gonna be there when they show up to
these things and then suddenly they're
they are having a beer with Norman
Reedus not knowing what the hell to say
you know also there's like there's a
dearth of uncomfortable silences as well
until they limber up a little bit and
realize that they're not being biessed
here you know I want to turn back once
again to our filmmaking listeners you
know all of us are working on carving
out a career for ourselves you know what
would you say would be five building
blocks that we have to have five five
things we have to be aware of if we're
gonna if we're going to be trading and
distributing film for a living
ah number one would be making sure that
you have talent and if your mommy and
your friends think that you're talented
that doesn't mean you have talent you
know when complete strangers approach
you and say I like what you read I like
I mean I like what you wrote so you know
I like what you do directing I like well
how you acted there then you might have
something to you got to go to where the
business is I don't take anybody
seriously who doesn't live in Los
Angeles or New York if they're gonna be
a filmmaker and you're three you then
have to find your way in I think we were
discussing this earlier there's no clear
pathway I can give kids say do this this
and this call this number talk to this
guy and suddenly you could have a film
career there just isn't a doctor dot for
that every story is different every
filmmaker has success in a completely
different manner mine was the strange
one too you know so there's no real set
of rules that you can follow and get
success in the film business you just
have to be near it be talented and find
your way in and in Boondock Saints you
focus on camaraderie is this something
in your own life that you admire you
know having a group or a family of
people that have your back and you think
that fans are drawn to the film because
of this camaraderie aspect oh sure they
are I'm sure they are you know it's uh I
think it's something we all here for
I've always had a crew of very close
friends and of course my brother Taylor
and even being in a band that's like a
de facto family you know so camaraderie
has always been important to me I
believe that it resonates with the fan
base too because even people that don't
have brothers or sisters yearn for those
types of relationships so for some weird
reason it's kind of its kind of been an
ongoing theme the boondock and as and as
clicked on to the fan base pretty good
now Troy looking back over these 10
years that it took you to you know to
make the original boondocks and now the
sequel and and I guess just your career
thus far in general if you could go back
and change anything
you know would you change anything and
if you would what would you change well
yeah I mean you can you can you can sink
like that and go back over every single
mistake you've ever made in the business
to things I would change are I want to
go on with new line the first time
around housing dear Max and I would have
liked to have been one of the things I
realized over this 10-year period is
that you have to play the politics of
this business it is a necessity you have
to know where to compromise well not to
compromise you can't burn bridges you
can't leave people feeling like they've
been insulted or or you know sidestepped
and you have to go through the proper
channels so I wish I have knew more
about the politics of this business and
how and the etiquette of this business
so those would be the two things that
come to mind right away
however our mistakes define us the
reason I know a lot more now and them
better at it now is because I made those
mistakes so I wouldn't really you know
click a button and go back and do it the
right way if I could besides we've got a
hell of a result out of it and with that
we've been talking a lot about the fans
on this show already trying and at this
stage what I want what we'd like to do
is we like to turn the show over to the
fans so we're gonna start getting to
some of their questions right now we
have this question is from filmmaker
Matson Tomlin comic book movies are the
craze if you could get your hands on a
franchise what would it be hey I don't
know I've never really been into comic
books which is strange because we're
actually all in a comic book to boondock
which is coming out in a few months and
it's always kind of a comic book feel to
it it's almost like these guys are
blue-collar superheroes they even get
their own superhero getup and stuff like
that I can see where he's coming from
but you know these comic book movies I'm
kind of getting sick to death of any old
comic book they're making into a
freaking movie now even ones that
weren't really that big in terms of
common being you know in terms of the
comic where it first came out you know
I've had it up to here with that I'd
like to see some people do some original
work
and then make a damn comic book out of
it we have another question from Riley
dukes Riley writes mr. Duffy I'm a huge
Boondock Saints fan I think you all did
an amazing job on the sequel I first saw
Boondock Saints when my parents rented
it one night while I was off babysitting
I came home and they were already about
20 minutes into it right when the
brothers are going into the elevator to
shoot the fat Russian guy I was about 15
anyway my question is what other films
do you have in store for loyal fans all
right
good question really there are two
scripts that I'm going to go out with
now and see if we can set it up one is a
one is a buddy comedy that takes place
in the 1500 is called the Good King it's
a black comedy that I've written the
other well the other one is called the
blood spoon council which is a serial
killer thriller that I've written so
we're gonna try to set one of those two
up within the next few months and
hopefully I'll be shooting that this
year okay very nice we have one from
someone named seven and their twitter
addresses at through the lens on twitter
seven rights in the first Boondock
Saints the twins show and knowledge of
weapons most pistols aren't hard to work
if you know the basics but carbines m4
Plus aren't straightforward where does
that come from were they in the army or
in the IRA no no I think that that's
just again what we were talking about
the comic books a superhero thing of it
they can just do it it's it's just a
prodigy thing if you got two guys that
believe they're you know destined by God
to be you know killers who rid the world
of evil I'm not gonna go into some
backstory about how they can do all this
stuff it's just accepted because they're
Connor and Murphy you know the same
thing with the languages they know they
just know and their explanations are
very short
you know we studied hard in school with
superheroes they can just do
but we have this question in from
Christy Troi what what made you know
that Norman Reedus and Sean Patrick
Flanery were going to be the McManus
brothers what what did they have that
others didn't
they had a unmistakable chemistry not
only when they acted together the one
they just hung out together so I got a
second these guys met they were
finishing each other's sentences so it's
just a feeling you know it was a feeling
that we had when we first saw Norman
Sean unfortunately
Miramax at the time did not have the
same feeling so I try to do a screen
test to show them and then dedup being a
fight but at the end of the day I know
that we made the right decision on that
so Troy I'm curious when you're not on
the tour bus take us through a day in
the life of Troy Duffy how do you
prioritize your day you know what gets
you up in the morning yeah I'm not much
of a morning person but like I said I
read constantly I try to keep creative
all the time but you know plank my
guitar a little bit here and there
work out a script iton up you know
things reread some my older stuff and
you know that kind of thing spend time
with my lovely wife I have two dogs I
love them very much and also a biker I
ride my motorcycle all over the place so
you know it's a luckily this fan base is
afforded games and the courtesy of not
having to have a real job so it's kind
of a nice life if you can get it you
know Tori something we didn't quite
touch on but you know you did mention it
but I would love some more specifics on
it you know during that the the eight
years or ten years whatever was in terms
of the first one in the second one that
there's there's all these years where
were you know where did the money come
from how did you how did you really
sustain yourself over all those years if
you're not going out if you're not
making another film you know how to just
his name well I mean it got pretty thin
for a while there man
sure sure but it was it was the fans
basically them you know the second I
opened up that lips
started selling boondock merchandise
signed scripts and stuff like that
posters they started buying it and it
wasn't always enough to you know cover
but we then started selling our stuff in
retail in this retail chain called Hot
Topic and they were able to do much
higher volume so all of a sudden we had
enough money to fund our lawsuit which
we then initiated at that point so it
took years to go through all that but I
think the fans don't know this thing
they kept a roof over my head in the
food in my mouth over the last ten years
and funded a lawsuit by buying t-shirts
they got boondock to made that way and
from their demand and continuing to buy
this movie over and over again I hardly
can think of a director who's more
important to a fanbase than myself
and then and what specifically what kind
of merchants that was more there was a
t-shirts I mean what else were you
selling originally from your website
originally I think all we saw was one
t-shirt a sign script and then it
started getting more like button
stickers pins flasks more t-shirts
hoodies thermals like you know any
anything will bloom back on it these
kids just snapping right up
and Tory can you touch on on something
that you've learned obviously you've
learned a lot over the last 10 years but
can you touch on something that you've
just learned in the last couple months
that that really excites you as you move
forward nothing really comes to month
well yeah okay one of the things that
excites me is we profess theatrical
release this time though it be in
limited release for 1.2 and only made 11
million dollars in six weeks I can and
this is Durham you know Twilight
transfire thing and avatar coming out
that's against some pretty hefty
competition but we weren't in as many
theaters mile-long stretch as those guys
what I learned is that again I mean it
really isn't
not necessity it is really nice to have
a be absolutely snaps TV on behind you
it was it was cool to have that
experience now I hope the next one we
can go into wide release and go even
further and I'm also looking forward to
you know having a larger budget to work
with
because in independence film a lot of
times you have to creatively solve
problems because you don't have money
diet just seemed it feels like to be
able to put your exact vision of
something on so rather than have to you
know find creative solutions for
everything okay and these last couple of
minutes were you know would you mind
kind of bringing everyone up to speed in
terms of where you are right now with
with Boondock Saints and I know you're
you're on tour now you you have a
national screening of the original
Boondock Saints that's hitting theaters
March 11th can you just bring us up to
speed I know you also have the DVD
release can can you kind of just sum up
for everyone where everything's dance
yeah I mean that that's a really
interesting one to me and after ten
years were finally getting a theatrical
release on boondock one which again is a
testament to this fan base that doesn't
happen guys I mean name me the film well
that's happens after 10 years they
actually put the things in theaters
although it's only for one night it is
across the country so we're really
excited about that and you know I'm in
word we're doing a gig here in New York
was a Tuesday night Tuesday night we're
doing a gig at Webster Hall in New York
and then we're doing Paddy's in Boston
at this awesome club called the paradise
so we're just kind of out here partying
with the fans right now and that's kind
of where I'm at and I think that I mean
if you want to extend the analogy even
further trying to you know cobble
together a list of films where the
sequel is even viable after 10 years
usually anytime you want to make a
sequel you have a two year window to do
that and then people just forget and
it's over Moondog stayed alive and
there's more alive today than it was
yesterday so you know that's where I am
right now and then up in the womb
fanbase and when are we when are we
gonna get the DVD release of Boondock
Saints to the DVD comes out March 9th
which is what we're doing in New York
and Webster Hall that's our DVD release
party but you guys are still only gonna
be down there a bunch of the actors and
then have a couple bands performing from
the soundtrack of the sequel my own
brother Taylor will be performing I'm
actually picking up my acts after 10
years and jump on stage with him to do a
couple of numbers but you know that's
that's kind of where we're at right now
I mean the DVD drops on the 9th so far
you know we've done amazingly well in
pre-sales and it looks like it's gonna
be just as hot as the first one you want
to thank writer director Troy Duffy of
The Boondock Saints and the boondock
saints - All Saints Day you can find out
more about the film's the tenth
anniversary tour The Boondocks tour with
official merchandise and lots more at
Boondock Saints calm
thanks again Troy thank you joy that was
awesome